uh this morning you'll have noticed
we're reporting on the flow of migrants
from north africa to europe officials on
the italian island of lampedusa say
thousands are attempting the journey
each week
uh let's head over to greece now and
talk to christy leftering and she's an
author whose latest book focuses on how
migration affects motherhood she's also
worked with afghan refugees herself and
christie really good to see you this
morning um
let's start though first with the book
itself um songbirds a focus
on migrants and their tales just tell us
a little more about it
well um i decided to write songwrits i
mean i've dedicated my career and my
research to exploring and understanding
the treatment of migrants and refugees
um and in my latest novel my latest
novel songbirds is set in cyprus
and it's about
it's based on a true story about
five migrant
domestic workers and two children who
went missing in cyprus
a few years ago
and unfortunately the authorities and
the police wouldn't search for them
because they were foreign
so the novel seeks to understand the
deeper voices of these women and to
understand the sacrifices and the
reasons for making such incredible
journeys and the and what they're
actually met with the treatment that
they receive once they um once they
arrive and they're kind of in the
country that they um hope to stay in i
mean certainly that the past few years
will have provided ample source material
uh for your novel there are countless
heartbreaking tales in real life of the
situation that migrants face but as
mentioned you have worked with afghan
refugees yourself i wonder
your thoughts about what you have seen
in terms of the collapse of that country
over the past few days
so um
when in 2016 and 2017
i worked at a refugee center in athens
where actually i am now in athens um in
a women and children's center which was
a place for safety for women and
children there was a a play area for
children and an area for new mothers who
had given birth on the journey so we're
talking about 2016 2017 and i heard so
many stories about people who um were
were fearful of staying in their own
countries
who loved their home but had to leave um
and
were and arrived in greece or wherever
else they were arriving because often
they'd they'd gone to many other places
as well before getting to greece but
they arrive in these places hoping to
find acceptance security
safety
um and often
um
be met with the opposite
um and
i you know i remember there's so many
stories i could tell about
children who you know i went back after
2016 it was a drop-in center in 2017 it
turned into an activity center so we
were teaching um german well i was
teaching english and greek and i could
see how much these children wanted to
learn wanted to have an education wanted
to have a hope for the future
and this is what i've learned from
listening to the stories from even
writing my current book songbird what it
means to make incredible journeys and to
to as human beings and this is something
we all i think have in common is that
desire that need that we have to have a
hope for the future and what i've seen
in my research
is um and you know in the last few days
seeing what's happening it makes me
incredibly sad because i realize how
fearful people were then
and the the situation now is so much
worse
and i can only imagine now what people
are going through i am so sorry christy
we are entirely out of time but i think
people understood what you were saying
there i really appreciate you really
appreciate you joining us in the program
thanks very much